what have you observed as some of the
mistakes you see other comedic actors
making in terms of timing really
overacting you know what you've seen
well the the first thing that comes to
mind is something that I used to do all
the time and it was too if I was either
auditioning or having booked the job and
going in to work on a sitcom for example
with one line two lines three lines is
to try to milk all the funny that I can
out of those lines and try to be a funny
cast member and the truth is the funny
lines are given to the regular cast of
the series regulars they're the funny
ones we're here to support them and to
be the straight man and and to you know
just participate in the telling of that
22 minutes story and then it's not about
me it's not the Steve Tom show it's not
all about me I'm just there to enhance
the performance of the series regulars
and I think that mistake I made that I I
made that mistake constantly for a while
but somehow I was still able to to
bookwork and but you know eventually you
you just learned you know and it's
through repetition and through failing
sometimes and making mistakes but that's
a big one that's a big one in fact
that's the biggest one that I can think
of yeah and I also think it's important
for actors to know the difference
between approaching a multi-camera
sitcom and a single-camera sitcom
because the techniques are different and
so they should Google multi camera and
single camera and read read about those
and learn the difference between the two
and I
that will really serve them well I think
in the long run can you share any tips
on single cam versus multi cam yeah in a
single camera sitcom very tightly edited
performances are more possible and and
retakes are really sort of a necessity
in that area and it's um it's sort of a
much more subtle performance I think in
a multicam situation those sitcoms are I
would say most of the time filmed in
front of a live studio audience and so
it's a little bit of a more theatrical
performance as if you're doing a play
because you have an audience there you
the timing is different you have to wait
for the laugh from the audience
and they and you don't necessarily do
that in a single cam sitcom so there are
you know there are these subtle
differences and every actor should know
the difference between those two
techniques and learn them yeah so going
back to what you said before that you
thought was so crucial it's almost like
an extra who's overacting in a scene
when you're really supposed to be in the
background so similar for some of the
smaller comedic parts let the the big
players be the the wainy characters yeah
and and and you're the straight person
yeah yeah it's not the Steve Tom show
yeah and you know but in it and it I
wasn't approaching it in that way
because I thought it was the Steve Tom
show I just I wanted to be it was a
sitcom I wanted to be funny and
sometimes you just don't have to be you
just attach more importance to it then
contextually it actually has in the in
the teleplay
just be your character you don't have to
be the star of the show
you